je trouve ça insultant quelqu'un bien de
chez nous le procès de ce tassement
balle comme le dit comme seule une
hôtesse blanche vraiment à lui patrick
clément s'est récemment fait voler un
colis déposés devant sa porte
il s'agissait d'un cadeau acheté en
ligne pour l'anniversaire du jeune fils
de sa copine absent mais mon voisin
j'appelle mon voisin gagés sur des colis
je me suis dit j'ai le dérangerait pas
j'arrive dans environ une heure ces
lapins jour ce vendredi le moment
télétravail mais la caméra de
surveillance de son voisin montre qu il
ne s'est écoulé que quelques minutes
entre le moment où le livreur a déposé
paquet et celui où le voleur est reparti
avec je vais en faire comme mon voisin
journaux
patrick clément n'est pas le seul à
avoir été victime d'un vol de colis
selon un sondage du transporteur fedex
auprès de 15 cents canadiens
une personne sur trois dit en avoir été
la cible cette année alors qu'en 2019
elle était un peu moins soit environ une
personne sur quatre
le service de police de la ville de
montréal n'a pas de statistiques sur le
vol de colis il juge toutefois fort
possible que ce type de vol est connu
une augmentation avec attendait mi6 et
les gens ne sont pas lors d'une seule
mais on les invite ce soit les fêlures
et au travail si les gens sont que je
retravaille demander à un voisin
justement car la livraison est attendue
de ramasser les colis l'office de
protection du consommateur rappelle pour
sa part que ces commerçants qui a la
responsabilité de s'assurer que vous
recevez votre colis le commerçant est
responsable et parfois on va site vous
renvoyer vers le transporteur où on va
vous envoyer une photo du corps lui qui
est sur le pas de votre porte
mais tout cela ne change rien au fait
que vous ne l'avez pas reçu et donc vous
disposez d'un droit d'asile à sion pour
patrick clément
l'histoire se termine bien il s'est fait
rembourser son achat et a pu offrir un
cadeau à l'enfant de sa copine c'est que
était accompagné compris la situation
puis j'ai permis de haut lieu que j ai
lu avec une figurine imposé il ya eu le
choix de toutes les figures guide est
disponible sur amazon depuis 1 h au mas
y en a choisi une personne eric naufrage
au canada montréal